ووضع الرئيس خطه
لعمليه الانقضاض عليه الخطه كانت محفوفه
من مخاطر يعني انه بعد اطلاق يعني تحريره
وين راح يروح الرئيس يعني راح يبقى ايضا
مطارد
نفدت بالفعل في مره من المرات احدى هذه
العمليات لمحاوله تحريره بعد ما طلب
الرئيس ووضع وضع خطه ركن يعني القوه فوج
لتحرير او قوه اي قوه فوج لتحريره مشغله
المطار مشغلة المنطقه الخضراء القضاض عليه
خطه كامله متكامله
وتمنقل المعدات الى القريب يعني على
الموقع اللي هو فيه
طلب مني ان يعني انقل هاي الخطه
النائب المرحوم عزت ابراهيم
ليضع يعني لمسات عليها
والقصد حتى يطمئن انه الخطه لانه عده
محاولات جرت لتحرير رئيس ولكن وراها ايران
لانه الايرانيين كانوا متقنين انه
الامريكان ما راح يسمحون باعدامه فحاولوا
عده محاولات
لاختطاف بحجه يعني انهم تابعين لفصائل
المقاومه
فاخبرت اني بهذا الموضوع قال يعني حتى
النائب يضع لمساته يعني بالموافقه اخبرت
احد ابناء عمومته يعني رجل كان من
المرافقين ورجل حريص على الرئيس ووفي له
وراحه يبلغ النائب وبقع عالق مده 21 او 23
يوم يعني لا هو اللي يقدر يوصل النائب
الله يرحمه ولا هو فمن رجع يعني من رجع
ايضا وشع يعني اوشو بهذا الرجل واتم
اعتقاله يعني هذا الرجل مخلص اللي راح حتى
يبلغ النائب بموضوع
التحرير التحرير رئيس من ما قدر يوصل يعني
فشل بالوصول الى لاسباب
يعني يعرفه هو ويعرفوه كثير من العراقيين
من رجع تمت الوشايه به وتم اعتقاله مده
طويله شو بتقصد بيعرفوها العراقيين يعني
اسباب لوجستيه او شو اسباب تتعلق بماذا
لعدم قدرته للوصول الى عدم
قدره نعم عدم قدر لاسباب يعني بعضها
خشيه النائب عن احد يعني وبعدين يرشد
القوات الامريكيه عليه يعني هاي احد ابرز
الاسباب فما اوصل
الرئيس العراقي الاسبق في مره من المرات
كيف سمع اصوات الرصاص وهو في داخل المعتقل
وتم ربط الموضوعين ببعض انه بعض عمليات او
احدى عمليات محاوله تحريره قد تكون هذه هي
اني يعني
بالحديث
بعد يعني بلغني هذا الرجل انه ما قدر يوصل
وتم المشاي بيه يعني ابلغت وتم اعتقاله
جيت بزياره الرئيس فليت الرئيس بضع يعني
صحي يعني يرثى له عيونه حمر منفوخات ووضعه
تعبان
فقلت له شنو القصه قال لي اني اسبوع كامل
كان يعني الامريكان صار لهم يلحمون يعني
يجيبون اقفال كبيره قال مشى ما شايفها قبل
قال بدوي يلحمون على البوب
[موسيقى]
الوميض اللي يطلع من من يعني ماكينه
اللحيم بدها تؤثر على النظر هو فعلا يعني
يشتغلون الليل كله الليل ما كان يقدر ينام
ما كان يقدر ينام فقال واحد جاي يعني اللي
افتهمت من الامريكان هو حكى لي واحد جاي
ورامي يعني
المكان اللي انا فيه وعلى هالاساس يعني
الامريكان عملوا العمل ورا فتره اتصل علي
شخص من دوله عربيه يعني يغيروا الاقفال
يغيروا يغيروا اقفال احتياطات اكثر بس ما
نقلوه لا ما نقلوه
من كانوا يغيرون بالهاي وهو موجود
فاتصل علي شخص
[موسيقى]
اختار انه عدم تنفيذ العمليه وقال يعني
بالحرف الواحد اني ما اريد اخسر اي عراقي
يموت بسببي
فاتركها وليدي